i went on a screen i was 10 years apart
yeah you went on a speed date yeah
when uh like two years ago how'd it go
uh well my girlfriend kept calling me at
the time but it was cool i messed up i
matched up with this like older chick
and mature women loved younger guys oh
bro he he had this
one older chick oh my god she did it
she was like you don't come over here
you all saw the guy i saw the guy yo she
you can just tell you can just sorry
peter gabriel
damn dog salisbury yo that older chick
she type oh
she's oh yeah she types over she's like
your mom because i oh my god
hey listen i sent her like she sent me
this little droopy at
her breast she sent me a naked picture
of her
and i showed chappelle the thing is all
the way down to kneecap right
swingers [ __ ] she's like like
60. yeah yes but she but but but hold on
wait
you don't bring that dick over here yeah
i took a i took a picture with my shirt
off where she's yeah he's like sending
pictures
back i was like dude like yeah
she was like oh you got me hot up in
here yeah you got me hot up in here
was she a black lady she was a black
lady yeah yeah
i came over here
bro we had to go on dates at like three
o'clock cause she gets she gets sleepy
at six
first of all she had roommates yeah i
forgot about that old woman
i go over there i go over there
is this the plot of grandma's house what
the
[ __ ] i was like malik i was like you
don't have to do this
why were you why were you i was in a
dark time uh yeah you were in the
darkness
ages
holy [ __ ] 68 you got me hot over here
yeah over here
yeah and that's how she that she typed
she typed it like that here she
she didn't put here did she look 60
kinda no
no no she was like 60 in the face no in
her face no but in the body yes
yeah her body was everybody but you
could tell like body when we had sex it
was weird yeah
you didn't tell me that part oh i
thought i thought we discussed it
gee you didn't tell me that you are a
jack of all trades well no what no hold
on i don't discriminate but
again i was going through some you know
big sean but but oh
but she didn't look 68. she her body was
she was 68.
yes like 68. 70 years old [ __ ] dude i
feel like this is illegal black don't
cry
yeah she was a black lady she was like
look like her mind like if you
saw her walking down the street do you
have a picture yeah oh
i don't know we don't we can't get rid
of that you don't have no show me
but we won't show the fans okay all
right dude 68.
hey you know what's funny we're going to
draw the line he was brad we were at
swingers one night
you know that diner swingers oh yeah
yeah yeah we're out there one night
and uh he was bragging to me he goes
yeah i've been talking to this shawty
man this he said shawty
i was like shawty i was like let's see
and then he shows me
60 60. were you like damn doctors
i understand if you're looking for some
like cougar to pay your bills
she had a roommate she had rumors you
know she invited me over
uh she invited me oh you know she
invited me over i was like
i was like i was like dude she probably
had grandchildren
she sounds like yo you can't live with
you oh did she say that
grandchildren oh yeah yeah she said that
this is insane to me dude yeah he better
hey with the j spot dude
shoot or shoot so this old lady
dang it see i'm saying have you ever the
best picture is that the good angle
that's this is no this is our best
picture right here but you can just tell
hold on her with the grandkids oh no no
that's kobe you could teach her kobe
hold on
is this a video her look let me love
dance here's a video right here
that's what i'm saying and she has a
birth date on there as well
thank you thank you thank you can i see
that too after you
yeah i'll show you our texts
i was like cracking me up yeah i'll show
you a text bro
the text were so funny yeah it's real
deal like but
because he was he was sitting here
sending pictures with his shirt off i
was like dude what are you
what are you doing all right
she's the best 68 thank you thank you i
appreciate you let me know
now and sure i'll show you the little
little
yeah that little nipple was hanging
that's not thank you bro like don't let
no no no
take it back i'm not hitting any and
everything out here i'm hitting bad ones
now
and she came i met her at a comedy show
and she was like look at him still
broccoli
i want to see this already
she does not look sexy i argue that she
looks every bit of 45 though yeah that's
what i'm saying you you're only good
you wouldn't be able to tell 60 yeah no
idea yeah and
she came on to you and was like yeah she
was like listen young man that's how she
approached me
that's hilarious she said i swear to god
and how long were you guys like just
it was like like it wasn't that long was
it no it was like two months but it took
me a while to get in their pants i was
like
what are we waiting on like you know
it's the same with her roommates that's
why oh so remember okay okay
so she's like time is hot on you
we gotta get going here
what do you want to do she was like
let's just get to knowing you she looks
she
said looks younger than me that's being
real here yeah she's better than i do
yeah she's insulted okay
so i'll actually she was like yeah she
was like she kept she was like man
what's your name
andy i was like man what's your name
yeah he's like she's from the south by
the way oh fantastic so
man what's your name she had some game
she had some games she's like yo and
respected
well listen i love pick me up so she was
like listen i want i'm gonna take you
out
she that's what she got me but i end up
paying for the date but we went to
we went to this place called simply
wholesome on libre and
and uh was it slauson okay okay and we
with vibing and that's like an
older mature like black restaurant so
yeah i'm the youngest one there
by far by far but you know
i'm being serious and they had like a
band planned
and she was like well tell me a little
about bit about yourself i was like
listen i don't know
and you never want to ask a woman like
her age but i'm thinking like she's like
35 45
she was like wait 35 okay okay all right
well i definitely
gotta forget he's in his twenties i mean
yeah yeah i'm a young girl i would have
been like uh she has to be at least
mid forties okay yeah she looks me like
just guessing but she had makeup on and
made her look younger okay
okay well you saw her yeah that's what
i'm saying she's bad yeah
for for for but she's she told me she
sprung it on me and she was like how old
are you
i was like well i'm 20 i was 26 at the
time and she was like
man how do you you know how old are you
and she was like
flip you that number backwards and add
like shouting at five or something like
that
i mean you know i'm not good at math so
i was like
[ __ ] her i was like i was like all right
no
well sweetie i'll flip that back
she kept saying like you know man i'm
i'm in my 60s
damn that's not and i was like crazy i
was like well she's enrolled in the 60s
did she just she was on celeste did she
come here to pursue acting and didn't
work out
nah she was over here she's that works
at a law firm but she i think she got
fired at the time but she collected like
a
a citizenship whatever that check
citizens the senior
senior citizens yeah that check so when
you retire
but she made that's all i heard
she was single does she have like a
rolodex of young dudes no she was single
and she had
but i think she wasn't getting laid
because she had like this crazy roommate
now her roommate was like this old white
woman
it's a funny story so they had this two
bedroom apartment
and when you get in there yeah listen it
was so old i know this i know the
apartment oh they had moth balls in it
what's that them a little more balls on
the white things that
like for like the roaches are the rats
no well for the office
i'm sorry
but they had that in the open and she
was like excuse me
my roommate is my roommate is nasty i'll
say well you got a roommate
she said don't worry about that don't
worry about the roof yeah there it is
the motherboard
of those i saw that i was like ugh you
just don't have that business
smell yeah exactly that's crazy
so how did you guys just like get
fizzled out she was like she found
somebody or something nah
hey look hey look look look i saw the
guy look i think she was trying to find
something she hit me
look thursday what did that say yeah
this thursday she says hey i'm not
your relationship hi you so awesome yeah
but that was it was it was i mean but
sex was with an older woman i would not
like i would not advertise that it was
so wack like she was like hold on you
got sold out young fella i was like hold
up wait wait
she was like yo let's stop let's stop
for a minute we stu we took like four
breaks and she was like okay who young
and she just kept saying
just saying yeah it was amazing out of
breath like hold on i'm like we just
started didn't you just barely
catch black play
that's a good way to catch polio
you're so [ __ ]
[Applause]
hey all the women they do shoot man i
got a hand job from uh
you testified
until i thought we were testifying you
came in speak your truth man
it was at the viper room you know the
viper room on sunset
vibe yeah were you there to watch it
band yeah i was there this is back in my
drinking days
and what happened some old chicken i was
going to see uh this band called eagles
the death metal
shouts out the eagles the death metal
that old lady is coming out
bro she looked like she been she looked
like she'd been hanging on sunset for a
minute yeah yeah
see what happened so um
we're sitting there waiting for the the
headlining band to come on he goes to
death metal
and uh we're standing there and she she
looks at me she goes you're hot and
here's the thing she was with her
boyfriend yeah and i was like oh okay
and she would
she was like isn't he hot he's so hot
you know i was like
oh okay lady you know what keep going oh
and then um her boyfriend was like uh
i'm gonna get us some drinks so he
he goes to get some get them some drinks
you included
no not me i already have i had my
[ __ ] what did i have a [ __ ]
pbr okay uh past blue ribbon shout out
and uh
he leaves and then she just grabs my
my crotch area and i was like holy [ __ ]
i was like what are you doing she's like
you're just so hot and i was like okay
you know you gotta i was like you got a
man
yeah you know i'm not if you forgot
about that yeah yeah i was like i'm not
trying to come between you you and your
man yeah
you know what i mean she's like how old
do you think i am i was like i'm i'm not
gonna
guess that she goes i'm 49. and i was
like you don't look 49.
she looked a little bit older oh bruh
she was like you know you know how vince
neil looks
yes she was like that yes but she wasn't
as
she wasn't like fat yeah but she like
but like that long hair
just like just that and uh
he comes back she puts her hand and
takes her hand away finally the band
comes on
and when the band starts playing she
just [ __ ] went
and just started jacking off while
you're watching the band while we were
watching
it was a husband and you let her do it
yeah
she started going and this is this is
what maybe made it stop all right oh you
didn't finish
no i stopped it i stopped early because
uh
when her boyfriend came back he was like
dancing on her and then he started
fingering her
oh so then i was like you know well
how'd it happen he was disgusting
was it wisdom no no they was pretty
they were rough they were yeah they were
pretty rough yeah it was
it was oh man yeah well her name was
dirty well like this at least it stopped
though you know oh yeah boys
cut that name out let me sing it too
yeah
and i was um 26 at the time 26 yeah yeah
again
it was for my 26th birthday i went down
to the viper room
not a bad birthday a little jack up
jaguar session yeah a little band
damn them old [ __ ] don't give up they
don't care she's just [ __ ] so
but how did you cut off with your old
timer you just kind of told her
i swear
well apparently she keeps wanting me
back um hi you
how you yeah
um we cut it off how did we cut it all
oh no i just i just like i said it
fizzled out she just kept having i think
sex wasn't there and then she like was
she kept wanting to go on dates and then
like in public we went on like four or
five dates and then
you went in public with her with your
conversation with your conversations
when she talked about like the old times
you saw
no she was just like she was really she
kept talking about like her her
she like i have children your age and
she's like you remind me she's feeling
her heyday she's killing it yeah she's
killing her yeah
she's she never stopped she's not and
she watched a lot of reality tv so we
talked about that
and i talked about like mine what would
you guys relate about you know what
i was gonna do some [ __ ] she was more
like a therapist like i've been to her
about like what i was going through
and then she'll try to like well she's
like yo back in my heyday what
we used to have and she just go in like
trying to relate to like y'all have good
conversations good conversation she was
great though yeah she was cool she's
been through something she's been
through a lot yeah it's cool
but she's she's like i said she's
enjoying life and she sure
is man yeah she she doesn't work but the
roommate situation tripped me out yeah
that's a bit of a bummer 68 with a
roommate yeah
i was not making the best life choices
well well it's just caught like it is
doug
68 with a roomie
yeah i do 16.
tell me keep it down my roommate yeah
could you date a 68 year old no i can't
i don't
know but then honestly looking at that
picture if she
wanted to hook up you know back then
yeah
you can just tell like her features and
i'm not even trying to make it a joke
right i swear to god i went over there
late night and she was giving me
fellatio
really and i i'm looking are you doing
that at 68. she do it
here's my thing she she's she i'm not
trying to make jokes
but she probably sucked she's probably
seen a lot of dicks so she's either
gonna be
bad with it or it's just maybe she's so
old school
it's not her thing it was it was no
in-between well she felt like she wasn't
really she just said
she's just a heady monster or she's just
bad at it yeah
she fell asleep
i'm not even trying to make a joke i'm
like oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] i mean she is that what you say
when you getting that
oh [ __ ] bro i'm not even making a joke i
look down like
like and she was dozing could you tell
like in her like your titties like
your ass was 68 yeah because i want to
show you this picture about deleted
don't
funny yeah just like yo you see like
booty oh man i was like if you
if you were single it'd be so fun man
i'm that i get these it was my darkest
videos
come on down here
[Music]
[Applause]
what's that show with y'all little
microphones
y'all you can't kill me friends go home
match comes on son
now i tell you little friends go home
you know mash comes on tonight
that sounds like the life man come on
now baby you know
i respect her all of you made me miss my
story dude i'm proud i gotta respect it
yeah i hope she finds a man
nah i mean yeah i have my business yes
you know
him back around yeah we had fun though
we had fun and uh i really
my mom thought my mom called me sick oh
she's older man your mom yeah i know
yeah i can't believe you told yourself
is your mom young yeah she's you know
and she looks very young i'll show you
my mom is 53.
she looks like she my mom's my brother's
banger my momma almost said your mom's
banging i know
you need you
hooked up with a 68 year old i mean my
dad thinks probably now no
he knows now you and dad have that
relationship where you guys can talk
about stuff like that yeah
we i was like yo he he talks i talked to
him about my six figure queen and he was
like man you're such a beta i was like
well
he's such a beta you respect that i mean
me and my dad really don't talk about
stuff like that yeah no
no no i remember one time i had this
girlfriend we tried doing long distance
and uh he came out here
and she was in miami he goes where's uh
blah blah blah i went oh she's in miami
and goes
oh how's that going we're doing good he
goes oh you
oh you don't think she's not and he
never talks to use you don't think she's
not [ __ ]
other dudes out there do you wait what i
don't think so he goes
of course she is brendan i was like
really ah he's right
he's right he was right wait wait you
pop's always right though yeah he's like
hey
you guys are young what do you think
he's doing out there he's in miami
yeah figured out dumbass that's even at
his age yeah
miami was like yeah what are you talking
about that's why that's why you don't um
oh your mom's super pretty
oh damn there's one little mom bro but
yeah she
looks 40 years younger than that lady
[Laughter]
she was like you said when i got off
stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just read a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song